okay uh good afternoon everyone
i would like to call the special meeting
of the ottawa police services board to
order for february 15 2022
on behalf of the board
let me start by apologizing for the
delayed start to our board meeting today
it has been a very busy day
uh i want to start also by recognizing
that ottawa is located on the unseated
territory of the algonquin anishinaabe
host nation the peoples of the algonquin
and ashnavik nation have lived on this
territory for millennia their culture
and their presence have nurtured and
continued to nurture this land the
ottawa police services board honors the
peoples and the land of the algonquin
and ashnavik nation today ottawa is home
to approximately forty thousand first
nations inuit metis people ottawa's
indigenous community is diverse
representing many nations languages and
customs the ottawa police services board
honors all first nations inuit and nichi
people and their valuable past and
present contributions to this land
we are currently broadcasting on zoom
and live streaming on youtube given this
meeting is being held electronically i
want to caution that there is a
possibility of technical difficulties
should we receive any disruptions i
would ask that everyone remain patient
as we work to fix the issues and resume
the meeting as soon as possible we have
set aside an hour for the public meeting
i would ask all panelists to do their
best to be concise in either their
questions or comments to ensure we can
stay within our timelines i will now
proceed with the confirmation of the
agenda
the police service has a late addition
they wish to add for the board's
consideration and that is the approval
of two special constable appointments
for carlton university since these
appointments do not relate to the
ongoing demonstrations i do not have the
delegated authority to approve them i am
looking to add this item to the agenda
with the board's consent per our
procedure by law any matter which was
not set forth in the notice calling the
special meeting requires the consent
recorded in the minutes of all members
of the board present and voting does the
board consent to the addition of our of
this agenda item
carried consent
[Music]
okay thank you for that uh so that the
ottawa police services board confirmed
the agenda for february 15 2022 is the
amended agenda confirmed
confirmed
of interests are there any declarations
of interests
seeing none
um item number one briefing on enhanced
integrated command center
on behalf of the ottawa police services
board i am announcing that today chief
peter slowly and the ottawa police
services board reached a mutually
agreeable separation and as such chief
peter slowly is no longer employed with
the ottawa police service
we thank chief slowly for his service to
the city of ottawa as this is a labor
relations matter no further comment will
be made
deputy chief steve bell will be the
interim chief until further notice the
board is already at work to put in place
a new command structure and will be
appointing a new chief very soon the
board's priority is to ensure a plan is
put in place to bring about a peaceful
end to the occupation of our city
i'm sorry
uh as expeditiously as possible the
integrated command center which includes
our rcmp and oc
opp partners will continue to operate
the first item on the agenda today is a
briefing on the enhanced integrated
command center i've asked the service to
provide an update specifically on this
new command center
and how it will impact the services
resource requirements command structure
and decision making moving forward i am
happy to see the rcmp and the opp at the
table because frankly the response to
this crisis so far has been ineffective
at bringing this occupation to an end
and restoring peace and security in
ottawa the ops has been unable to
adequately enforce our laws and our
residents continue to be terrorized it
isn't good enough last week the ops sent
a letter a clear message to the
occupiers to expect a trump a strong
police response to illegal activity on
the weekend there were more street
parties equipped with stages big screens
and sound systems hot tubs and an
outdoor gym were erected today we have
more trucks lined up on parliament hill
than we had yesterday like other
residents in ottawa i have watched in
disbelief as this carnival of chaos has
been allowed to continue while i
appreciate that resource constraints
have been a big limitation it's both
puzzling and frustrating to the op that
the ops
has been unable to do more
with the current resources and i know
resources have been a huge issue interim
chief bell i would turn this over to you
to introduce and once the presentation
is over we will go to questions from
board members so over to you and
thank you chair deans um it's been a
challenging day for the board it's been
a challenging day for the service and
i'd like to start by thanking chief
slowly for his service to the ottawa
police service and to the community
the unlawful occupation has been a
tremendous stress on our community
everyone that lives in ottawa and has
brought on unprecedented challenges to
both the police service and the city as
a whole
i know it's been tough i know it
continues to be tough but i'm confident
that we've reached a turning point with
the new resources that we've seen
flowing in from our policing partners
the new tools that both the province and
federal government have put in place and
our new integrated command center that
you're going to hear more about today i
believe we now have the resources and
partners to bring a safe end to this
occupation
the auto police are ready eager to do
what our what is our part with new
leadership and stability from our
command team i'm confident that we can
end this occupation we look forward to
continually working with the opp and
rcmp to restore law and order in the
city of ottawa i'll now turn it over to
deputy chief trish ferguson for an
update on our current efforts
thank you interim chief bell good
afternoon chair members of the board i
want to thank you for the opportunity to
provide you with an update on the
demonstration and some salient details
today
as has been the case following every
weekend to date the number of
demonstrators
and vehicles in the downtown core has
dissipated the number of demonstrators
was less than 150 in the overnight hours
and the numbers of vehicles in the core
has declined to approximately 360.
this is down substantially from the
beginning of the demonstration where
there were over 4 000 vehicles in the
downtown core
and it is lower relative to all other
periods of the demonstration as well
the overall footprint of the
demonstration remains more or less the
same though a small number of trucks
have been relocated from residential
areas
of the downtown core to wellington
street in front of parliament
this was an outcome of negotiations that
occurred between the mayor and some of
the demonstrators and it is hoped that
this outcome will help to limit negative
impacts being faced by the downtown
residents
as of this morning there are 172 active
criminal investigations
we have laid 33 charges
and made 18 arrests
and with bylaws help we have handed out
nearly 3 000 tickets
we appreciate that the community wants
us to increase our enforcement actions
uh though as we have said from the
beginning we are managing security and
safety throughout
what this means is that we're not always
in a position to lay a charge or ticket
on an individual due to a specific
security or safety concern at the time
it doesn't mean it cannot be done at a
later stage by different means of
service
we continue to actively collect evidence
information and intelligence
and we'll be working with our municipal
provincial and federal partners in
ensuring that there are consequences in
the days weeks and months ahead
realistically this means that our many
investigative teams will be doing months
of follow-up work with investigation in
order to lay charges when warranted
regardless of where an individual
resides
on the issue of the incident command
center
as has widely been reported the ops
the opp and the rcmp have moved to stand
up the incident command center
this center led by the ottawa police
will allow us to leverage a proven and
structured framework when conducting our
operations required given the
complexities and intricacies of the
continuing situation
the icc will allow for the oversight and
coordination of planning and logistical
supports and experts who continue to
arrive from across the country
these experts carry with them a great
level of knowledge and experience in
responding to such protracted
demonstrations and will be critical to
intentional scaled intelligence informed
actions as we move forward
in all cases and all actions and
decisions taken will be measured
made in consideration of all possible
factors and outcomes regularly evaluated
for positive and negative impacts and
adjusted as needed
finally the icc will aid in providing
of strategic communications to all
parties including members of the public
the media and our policing partners
as for the enforcement of recent orders
during the last few days a number of
emergency orders and actions have been
taken at the local provincial and
federal levels
these orders are helpful we welcome them
but must be fully understood prior to
application to ensure that they can be
used effectively and as intended
in the case of the federal invocation of
the emergencies act we continue to wait
for official details before
operationalizing it
we have been working with our legal team
and those of our provincial and federal
partners to understand the implications
of the various orders and actions and
consider the impacts on our ultimate
mission
this work has been continuing during a
time of high fluidity and so we have
taken the necessary time to understand
additional powers in the current context
and communicate this to our members
that said we certainly have more tools
in our toolbox today than we did when
this demonstration started
and we will look at how we can best
address them
and use them
to deal with public safety and security
concerns
thank you
okay thank you for the presentation
we'll start with questions from uh
member nerman
thank you
uh so acting chief bell
uh you have been part of the command
team during the current crisis which is
ongoing
so i have few questions and i hope i can
you can enlighten me on that
so we are on the 19 days into this
illegal occupation
do you think the residents of ottawa are
currently being provided
with adequate and effective police
services
uh thank you for your question remember
nerman so
um
from
a legislative requirement of
responsibility absolutely i do believe
that we are uh providing adequate and
effective policing and i think based on
the communication and partnerships we
have with the opp and the rcmp we are
increasing and improving our police
service provision on a day-by-day basis
um the geography of the occupation has
shrunk over the last number of days we
continue to work on ensuring safety and
security within the neighborhoods
because it is the neighboring residents
who have been most impacted
detrimentally through lack of feelings
of safety and security within where they
live that we've really been focused on
so um
for the last two weeks we've absolutely
been focused on putting resources into
those neighborhoods while we continue to
work with the illegal occupiers to leave
our city the uh the assistance we've
been provided by the rcmp and the opp
has been absolutely invaluable in
helping us to develop and deliver a plan
that you heard at a high level uh deputy
chief ferguson layout so that we can
engage with the communities around the
occupied area to ensure
increased safety and security and
continue to work and um work with the
occupiers to ultimately have them leave
the city
uh thank you thank you deputy bill my
next question is are residents or
whatever residents
who have given on the police are now
taking
to the streets in large groups to
confront and expel our illegal occupiers
do you see this type of action as an
indicator of a failure to provide
adequate and effective police services
um
so
i
we've said i've said from the beginning
we've said from the beginning i
absolutely have an immense amount of
compassion for the mem for the members
of our community who are so
detrimentally affected by this
occupation
we've called on people to not engage in
counter demonstrations not because we
don't have sympathy with them for what
is occurring in and around them but
because we're worried about safety
concerns we continue
we continue to call for people to be not
engaged in counter protests while we
apply our resources to remove the
occupiers from our city streets so
although i
deeply feel for the the strain um and
stress that has been placed on our
city's residents they need to know that
we are working
with our in ourselves and with our
partners to put a timely and effective
end to this
thank you my next follow-up is
is there a current plan to bring an end
to this illegal occupation i'm not
asking what the plan is
only asking whether a plan exists
and if so
did opp and rcmp contribute to that plan
and have they agreed to
your plan of action since obs is is a
lead agency on that
uh so thank you for the question um
and you're quite right in stating that
we can't provide any plan uh that we
would be engaged in what i can let you
know is um and i'd like to thank
commissioner lucky and commissioner
creek have said some of their best
people who have been involved in this
type of incident in other jurisdictions
to ottawa to support our teams in
developing the plan i can absolutely
assure you that we do have a plan to end
this illegal occupation in our streets
and we continue to work with them to
finalize resource and implement that
plan and remove the illegal activities
from the city
thank you dp and my final
uh final concern uh during the first
emergency board meeting uh which was
held on february the 5th
i asked
former chief slowly uh yourself and the
planning
acting deputy trish ferguson about
the blockades and highlighted the
decision of the supreme court of canada
in clayton case we discussed that length
the powers of the police in common law
for putting the blockage and was
uh and i also further asked whether
there was any planning or intelligence
failure on the part of the ops
now after the convoy provided advanced
notice to the of their intentions
why were occupies permitted to gain
access to the downtown downtown core
and specifically on day three of
this convoy the ops said that they had
no right to put up the roadblocks
touristic movements of convoy into the
city do you stand by that view
do you now agree that the police do have
the power to put the road blocks in
place where appropriate
and finally
and the final is do you
have an explanation why for how why and
how you did not know that at the start
of the
convoy and especially on day three
so thank you for the question and my
apologies again for uh for intervening
in it um so as we outlined in the
previous board meetings we we have
approached we approached this
demonstration in the early days uh based
on the intelligence that we were
receiving and based on the history and
um
unfolding of prior demonstrations that
we've seen within our downtown core
um all although the
we completely support and i know that
there's been a
motion made at council to ensure that
there's a review done in this we will
actively participate in that to look at
lessons learned and how we can refine
how something like this would unfold in
the future we continue to work with our
legal experts we continue to work with
our crown attorney's office to exercise
absolutely every lawful authority we
have to end this occupation
as we go through it we there's lessons
to be learned there is there is no doubt
in my mind we will learn those lessons
but i would like to focus on those once
we have these illegal demonstrators out
of our streets
off of um head of our city and our
residents own their city again
ah thank you just follow up i just want
to know
do you agree that the police have the
powers to put the roadblocks
in place where appropriate
even at the commencement of the convoy
in the middle and even now
do you agree with me uh with your
position or not
abs so member nurman as as i indicated
we will continue to use every lawful
method that we have in order to remove
the demonstrators from our streets uh
what we did on the first days and what
we would do what we can do now we will
use our legal authorities to make sure
that um we don't allow more people to
enter our downtown core and that we
remove them as expeditiously and quickly
and safely as possible
thank you thank you chair those were my
questions
thank you member member sueta
thank you chair um i just wanted to say
that i'm saddened to hear about chief
slowly and i want to thank them from the
bottom of my heart for all this service
to the city
um
acting chief bell
from the beginning there's been a lack
of resources and manpower
is anything changing now
do we have more resources coming and if
so when and how many
um so thank you very much for the
question um i'm going to turn it over to
deputy chief ferguson to talk about the
resources that are coming in but i'll
i'll again reiterate the support that
we've gotten from the rcmp and the opp
that has been continually building over
the last week has
been invaluable enough to get to a
position where we are right now where we
believe we're at a turning point in this
demonstration so i will turn it over to
deputy chief ferguson to outline some of
the resources that we've received and
some of the planning that we've been
engaged in
thank you and thank you member suede for
the question
um as you know the ask was put out about
a week ago now for
up to 1800 members from across
a number of services and we have
received incredible demand or incredible
response from our demand
and and i will say
echo
deputy bell's uh comments about the fact
that you know the opp and the rcmp have
provided a wonderful amount of people
and and not just uh numbers but skills
that we were lacking or that we needed
to round out our team uh to make it as
strong as possible i feel we are there
now we had provided them with three
different levels of staffing that we
were hoping to achieve one of them being
just strictly for maintenance uh the
other was to uh be able to improve our
posture and actually target some of the
the the activities that we spoke about
in our surgeon contain uh and then the
final one was for um you know what we
would have as a you know an actions
scenario so three different layers of of
staff and i think we are confident now
and uh in this integrated command center
able to determine what level of staffing
we need for each of those things
okay so i mean at one point i know the
province was suggesting i think they're
mentioning 1500 resources do we actually
have those right now
okay is 1500 here or is it a percentage
of that 1500
so
it's a bit of a complicated factor
because we're we're talking about
24-hour coverage so and we need to make
sure that people are rotated through and
have rest so uh there are times when
it's scaled up on the weekends we have
asked to have you know an increased
number of staff um and and we choose
days carefully to make sure that folks
are getting the rest that they need to
be able to maintain our level and
increase where we can um so i know it's
not a hard and fast exact number for you
right now
but it's also not um
not a wise thing to provide exact
numbers when we're talking about posture
for security and safety
suffice to say that we have had
a very satisfactory and and good
response to our ask
yes so and what um what i'll what i'll
add to that is is where trish left off
what we've seen over the past week is um
a steady and increasing transfer and and
um application of resources by both the
rcmp and the opp to our efforts in the
city
we're very happy with with the results
that we have in terms of our call for
resources called by the board chair
deans um and city council to have more
resources available to us um and the
reception of that so again i can't thank
uh commissioner lucky and commissioner
creek enough for not only the expertise
that they've helped provide us but the
resources in terms of of sworn members
that they are have provided us and
continue to indicate they will
increase over the days ahead
okay
and also i want to thank you as well uh
chief for stepping up and uh and filling
the role i know it's been tough on
everybody and just one more question uh
maybe this is to a cio dunker
are we still
okay with our financial resources that
have been proven
promised by the other levels of
government
uh we're certainly tracking everything
we're spending uh related to
um this occupation
uh we expect invoices from the opp and
the municipality and we will sort out
the cost recovery
uh mechanisms as we move along because
we're in you know pretty early days of
this from a financial recovery
perspective
and we believe that we won't receive um
invoices from the rcmp
um and we are working with the federal
government currently on the grant uh we
already have i think um the board is
aware of the grant line that was
associated with uh special events that
we get annually
so there's already that
conversation going on in terms of
recovering additional funding through
that process so
as i mentioned it's early days but we
are tracking every
um cost and we will bring that as part
of our our update our financial update
back to the board uh i believe it's in
march or april
okay and finally do we have a an
average cost per day
an estimate of what it's costing us
yes so i have as of yesterday the total
cost
um that we had tracked and it's
important to note that these are
recorded costs so not all over time for
example would be yet recorded and other
items would be coming trickling in so
we're at fourteen
point one three oh three five three nine
billion so fourteen point one million um
that does not um include the rcmp
costs if they were to invoice us so
that's for the ops cost plus um
forecasted costs for the opp
and municipalities and all ops costs so
that works out to about 785 thousand per
day
and as additional officers join those
costs will be going up so that was um
what we tallied as of yesterday
okay thank you very much and thank you
chair
thank you member suede um interim chief
bell i just i think we should clarify in
terms of the resources that i mean we're
pretty happy with how they're flowing
into ottawa now and that more are coming
and it's making a huge difference but i
don't want to leave the impression that
after we made that ask last
sunday or monday whenever it was that
those resources came in the way we
expected because they were very slow and
i i think we just have to be very clear
with the public that yeah we're we're
doing really well now and we can see
that we're at a turning point but that
was not initially the case so if you
could just confirm that yeah thank you
for that clarification chair deans
absolutely we made the ask um
about a week ago um and it's taken time
through planning uh and resourcing to
actually get those boots on the ground
in ottawa we are not at the 1800 number
yet uh we haven't seen that realized but
we continue to work with our partners in
the opp and the rcmp to make that a real
fact in our city so what we have seen is
an increase
um a steady flow of bodies into
our operation that are deployable but it
was not immediate as you indicated and
would it be fair to say that um the
escalation of resources into this
community for assistance with this
occupation
came
about at the same time as the integrated
command
uh new structure was put in place
so um
i think it's it's um fair to say that
the integrated command
center that we've established with the
opp and the rcmp has been of great
benefit for us to track the resources we
have allocate the resources that we need
and bring them into the city i don't i
don't think it is because of that but
what it has done is has added
capabilities to the operation for us to
be able to bring
resources in properly deploy them
towards efforts that we are undertaking
to end the occupation
thank you for that uh interim chief bell
remember me
thank you chair and um thank you deputy
chief uh i guess the question is i think
for a lot of folks in the city who are
really beside themselves
what's going to change now when are we
going to see action and i don't expect
you to give us a detailed schedule but
when can we expect those rigs and the
pickup trucks and some of the
paraphernalia that they're downtown when
can we expect that to be
action to begin to be to move that out
so it's um
as i as i indicated early on we we won't
lay out our operational plans in a
public forum we will brief the board as
is our responsibility in in an informal
session at the appropriate time what i
can tell you is there is absolutely a
plan that has been developed through our
partners at the opp and rcmp to have an
integrated approach and response to
ultimately end the occupation in our
streets so that plan continues to be
refined and developed and exists and
when is the appropriate time we will
brief the board on the execution of that
plan
okay um we saw in windsor when the
emergencies act was announced by the
premier
um the authorities down at the bridge
like sent out flyers to all the the
people who were protesting and
blockading the bridge and it laid out
the penalties that were going to be uh
you know meted out uh if the protesters
did not leave and that um that
information i think did a long did a
good job of informing people and
encouraging them to leave
are we going to prepare something
similar here because we know that a lot
of the people who are occupying are
getting information not necessarily from
mainstream media they don't know exactly
um if in fact the
the federal measures that were we're
going to bring in uh they don't know
about what that actually means they
don't know about the emergencies act
will we have a flyer that's going to go
out to everybody to spell out you could
lose your rig you could lose the
insurance on your rig you could
ultimately you you may not get a
mortgage if you you know if you stay
here will we be doing something similar
to that so they know exactly what
they're facing if they remain here
um so what what i can let you know and
i'll turn it over to trish ferguson to
top up on anything that she wants to
once i'm finished what i can let you
know is from day one of the occupation
we've let people know
jeopardy that they have around this
we've gathered information around who is
here so that at the end ultimate end of
this we can actually apply jeopardy
there can be penalties associated with
the illegal occupation in our streets we
continue to work the commanders that
worked with the opp and the rcmp in
windsor
we have access to and we continue to
rely on in order to build and develop
our plan we've been clear with the
protesters through community verbal
communications through twitter through
mainstream media through all of our
communication channels you cannot be in
our streets you shall you need to leave
our streets we will continue to escalate
that that discussion and the ultimate
enforcement of those directions until
they are gone from our streets okay
we're going into family day weekend here
the redo center's been closed for two
weeks uh people have been you know
you know forced to stay in their homes
um there's going to be a lot of people
want to go downtown i'm wondering like
is there
is there a plan to tackle some of the
the uh blockades that are keeping the
rito center from opening um i know that
there's uh i guess about 30 vehicles at
rito and sussex if that you know that
occupation was moved out then perhaps
cerritos center could actually open uh
is there
are you looking at prioritizing i guess
uh some of the areas that are impeding
uh you know businesses and people from
from accessing their their places of
work and business
so um we we continue to understand the
pressures that all of the blockades
cause on our downtown core and the
extreme
challenges it is creating for our
residents the safety concerns the
security concerns within their
neighborhoods
we know there are some pressure points
like rito and sussex and we continue to
to talk to the the demonstrators there
have discussions to negotiate uh their
way from that area ultimately out of the
city that will ultimately end in us
intervening with the removal of them
from our streets we continue to work on
that and as i indicated before as part
of the operational plan we will
brief the board in camera on how we plan
to move ahead when when that time is
correct
okay
um i i appreciate that um
do you have a timetable
you know off the record or you know
just say yes or no is there a timetable
we have an absolute plan on how we wish
to move ahead to end the occupation of
our streets okay um back in 2014 when we
had the terrorist attack on parliament
hill we saw
a surge of mounties come in to reinforce
the parliamentary precinct
is there any plan like that in the works
this time
so we as as i've indicated a couple
times that we continue to work with our
rcmp and opp partners um as chair deans
rightfully pointed out we saw a trickle
of resources come in in the early days
we're increasingly seeing our access to
resources grow over the over the days as
we engage in the integrated planning in
our integrated command center there is
nothing um that that
i've been told nothing that leads me to
believe that we don't have everything
but absolute coordination and
cooperation with both the rcmp and the
opp to release resources for us to get
these people out of our streets okay i i
know that you answered the question
about resources but uh the former chief
asked for 1800 uh bodies to come in are
we anywhere close to that are we getting
close to that is that still the target
so as um deputy ferguson indicated we
don't we we're not going to release a
number of operational numbers for safety
concern and for operational concerns
that that's a standard practice for us
and and makes even more sense in
circumstances like we are currently in
what i can tell you is we continue to to
receive resources there is unified
reporting on the number of resources
that we have that is sent to our command
team to
the opp and the rcmp executive so that
everyone has line of sight on the
resources that are in our city from all
of the different jurisdictions we
continue to see a day over day increase
in those and as we finalize plans we
will continue to see that grow over the
coming days
uh deputy chief thank you that that's it
for me thank you
thank you member man and i think some of
what you're hearing here is the real
desire of this board to hear more
details of a plan than obviously you can
share in public but i would ask for an
in-camera briefing
of that plan because
we need to be very satisfied um where
we're going at this point on this plan
so uh we can work that out interim chief
bell and we'll move to member smallwood
uh thank you terror um and i wanted to
join my fellow board members in uh
firstly thanking
uh former chief slowly for his uh uh
efforts he's been through some really
horrendous times coved and this
occupation have been extraordinarily
challenging we've never seen times like
this in the city before so i really want
to to do
say thank you uh it's been it's been
tough uh and i also wanted to thank
those who have stepped forward uh
uh you know acting chief bell
and uh and deputy uh trish ferguson and
the entire command team and the members
because uh
i think we'll look back on this and i've
said to many people you'll put this on
your cv all of us will put it on our cv
this is they will teach courses about
this they will talk about this for a
very long time to come
and uh and everybody is second guessing
why somebody didn't do something and and
what i can say for sure is is it
certainly isn't because i've never seen
anybody who doesn't have their entire
uh body geared towards making that get a
solution get a resolution to this we all
really really really want to do that and
i think you've seen some of the
questions and the board members
there's a there's a saying for board
members that our job is nose in and
fingers out
we can ask questions but we can't tell
you what to do and we also
we can't expect you because all we can
do is ask about operational matters but
we can't expect you to tell us certain
things and we can't direct you how to do
them so we do appreciate that and but
as you've seen that doesn't stop us from
asking the questions and uh and i think
it's helpful um
for the public to see even though
sometimes we know you're not gonna be
able to answer it at least we do our
best to try to
dig away at it to see what we can find
out i did have one question which i
don't think is operational but i just uh
deputy chief ferguson you mentioned that
there was uh 360
i think you mentioned i'm not sure i
wrote it down 360 vehicles
and 150 people downtown currently
did i get that wrong
so the figure was 360 vehicles and in
the overnight hours there were 150
people
protesters on the streets so that's how
we measure we check to see how many
people are on parliament hill how many
in the streets surrounding and obviously
that's a very fluid number and then how
many vehicles
because i just i was wondering if there
were
more vehicles than people but i'm
assuming then that there are actually
360 vehicles perhaps with people with or
without people in them and the overflow
people are in the streets
and i noticed that now one thing i
wanted to confirm
is just that
when a vehicle when a when a member of
the convoy leaves now i realize there's
this is
some question some part of it you won't
be able to but i realize there's some
negotiations that happen but in general
when a
convoy member leaves
they're not allowed to come back like
we're we're not like they don't have
some sort of pass that says you can come
and park here for
whenever you want like i'm i'm kind of
assuming that if somebody were to leave
that that we don't allow someone else to
come so the only
movement that we've seen about vehicles
was a uh i guess an arrangement that x
number of vehicles were on residential
streets would be allowed to move up to
wellington and the s jam parkway to get
them out of the residential area would
that be correct
i apologize um just had somebody come
into my office um
could you just like
you mean there's something going on is
there something going on i can ask you
questions so absolutely there there is
no right of return or in and out pass
for people in in the area we are
actively working every minute of every
day to limit the number of people within
the footprint and when we either
negotiate them to leave or they do leave
on their own accord they are not allowed
back and there is no one that is allowed
to come in and fill their space
and we've seen
we've seen success in that over
the last number of days the numbers that
we're reporting today are the smallest
number of of vehicles within the red
zone footprint that we've had since the
beginning of the occupation we have more
work to do
absolutely committed to do it but we are
seeing a decrease in numbers
so i really appreciate that because i
think what the public wants to know and
i appreciate you can't tell us when are
they all going to be gone but i think
what the public wants to know is every
day it's getting better there is hope it
is getting better there are fewer and i
know i've been down there on many days
and before it was just shocking that the
diesel in the air i mean it was
sickening and the tension that was in
the air so i'm really really happy to
see and i really do appreciate the work
and efforts of all the people involved
in this so thank you very much and thank
you chair
thank you member smoke
member smallwood member kane
uh thank you chair
uh under section 4.1 of the police
services act the municipality must
provide adequate and effective policing
concerning public order maintenance and
emergency response
with all due respect
i have found the provisions of these
services over the past three weeks to be
wholly inadequate and ineffective
so interim chief on behalf of the
residents of ottawa can you explain the
inadequacy of the law enforcement
efforts that we've seen during this
siege
so
we've we've had multiple discussions in
this forum about uh the challenges that
we were seeing in this unprecedented
demonstration in our city and not only
in our city but in other jurisdictions
across ontario and across canada so the
plans that we put in place are exactly
that to create public order and to make
sure that our members of our community
feel safe and secure in the city in
which they live we continue to build
capacities through our partnership with
the opp and rcmp to have the capacity to
take our streets back we have
absolutely developed the capacities and
have developed the plan to actually go
in to and execute and affect that return
of our streets so when you ask about
adequate and effective policing i did
answer that question earlier i do
believe that we have provided adequate
and effective policing and we will
continue to support
and the the communities need to feel
safety and security in the place they
live while we remove these unlawful and
illegal demonstrators from our streets
well interim chief i would uh beg to
differ with you and i'm certain many
residents would also beg to differ on
that we've seen um you know a scenario
uh where the lack of police action has
been inexplicable for many of our
residents we've seen the idling trucks
we've seen the idling generators
we've seen the assembly of jumbotrons
bouncy castles barbecues
most dangerously we've seen fuel dumps
full of gas diesel and propane canisters
people are being harassed in the streets
they can't go into stores uh they're
unable to enjoy any semblance of a
normal life supply encampments remain in
operation and residents have now taken
on the dangerous work of enforcement and
resistance in their own hands so i have
to say that i don't see
that um that effective and adequate
policing here um you know we've heard
from others including the minister of
public safety and emergency preparedness
who is a former toronto police chief
who has also said the lack of police
action has been inexplicable and i'm
saying as a member of the police
services board that the lack of police
action has been inexplicable so interim
chief
even if there has been inadequate
resources to address this crisis
why haven't there been the basic
probative enforcement exercises to
address the most blatant violations of
the law
you know maybe
on mass
it's going to take time to deal with the
situation but there have been many
situations many instances uh where
action could have been taken so i'm just
wondering why
weren't actions taken
as an example
you know we see the corner of rito and
sussex we see the the war memorial
why haven't specific actions been taken
in in in terms of those uh
incidents
so
what i'll start with is there's already
been committed to a review
of what led up to the point that we're
at today around this demonstration we
welcome that
um what i can see what i can sit here
and commit to you is a substantive plan
forward actions forward to end the
demonstration within our city
we know that over the past number of
weeks
several of if not all of those safety
concerns that you've identified have
existed within our streets they have
been completely unacceptable we have
from the early days identified that we
needed the resources to be able to
access to safely
stop these demonstrations in our city
the board through chair deans the
council through the mayor have actually
advocated for us to receive those
resources and in those resources in turn
we've been able to bring in partners
from the opp and rcmp to work
collaboratively together to to build a
substantive
definite plan that is properly and
adequately resourced to ultimately end
this occupation
we will continue to work towards that
plan to end the occupation in our
streets so that we see no more of those
unsafe activities
well
with the new integrated coordination
amongst agencies
if there has been an accelerated tempo
of incoming resources
when will we see an accelerated level of
enforcement in order to address the
illegal occupation
so i think over the past number of days
you've already seen an
increase in the enforcement activities
of our members in a more coordinated and
strategic way that is directed towards
ending the occupation as we continue to
uh roll out the plan and the occupation
you will see an ongoing increase in that
and will the integrated response of
multiple law enforcement agencies be
driven by a specific plan and when will
that plan be put into
place so again um
as is the responsibility of myself as
interim chief i will brief the board on
that plan of that operational plan
as we roll it out in in the time that is
required to me prior to doing that that
will need to be done in camera because i
would not want to actually provide
operational comments in an open public
forum about ongoing or future police
operations
thank you for that um notwithstanding
misinformation and disinformation that
is uh floating around uh the entire
ecosystem
are you aware of any complicity by sworn
members with illegal occupiers
so misinformation and disinformation is
has been a challenge and and a threat to
this entire operation as we've worked
through it
that being said what i can clearly state
now is
there
any any information that we have
received that there could be complicity
by any of our members or anybody
associated with this police service we
are actively investigating it to come to
a a resolution or come to a culmination
in terms of discipline that would be
associated with that
as the interim chief i could tell you
anybody that is supporting this
demonstration has no place in this
police service and will be dealt with
according
interim chief have there been any
illegal occupiers who have been charged
with unlawful assembly as defined in
section 63 of the criminal code
to this to this point no there has been
no uh none of the occupiers who have
been charged with that specific
legislation but there have been several
members that have been charged with
other criminal code violations
and i have some more focus pointed
questions here about uh what legal
advice led ops to allow trucks to move
freely outside of the designated city uh
truck routes um as we know
uh member nirman had pointed out r
versus clayton and brown versus
a durham region uh which
clearly states uh that uh there is
authority for police services to
restrict vehicular access into and
within the city so i want to know um you
know what legal advice was provided to
do that and uh what decision is going to
be made in the future to to actually um
ensure that uh this authority is applied
because it's obvious that uh roadblocks
can be uh utilized in in this scenario
so what i can let you know again is we
we absolutely encourage and we'll
support all reviews of the actions that
have been taken up to this point um so
that we can learn from what what
mistakes may have been made or what laws
we need to advocate to have tightened
sharpened or changed moving ahead to
avoid a situation like this from a
forward look we are continuing to work
with
our partners in the integrated command
center
as well as legal experts to look at what
lawful means we can use to
keep people from attending the downtown
core to add to the numbers of the
demonstration and lawfully and
expeditiously remove the uh unlawful
occupiers that are in our streets today
when was the demonstrated demonstration
uh now only illegal occupation the
clarity legal and if so when did this
take place
so you're gonna have to i'm gonna ask
you to refine your question i don't i
don't understand exactly what you're
seeking
so this went uh to perceivably being a
protest to an illegal occupation
uh was the demonstration declared
illegal and if so when did this take
place
so i'll i'll have to get you the
specific point at which we changed our
our view on it from a protest to an
illegal occupation i just don't have
that right
okay
um an additional question would be when
was the first request to the federal and
provincial governments for resources
when did that take place
and uh on what date and you might have
to get back to me on that as well yeah
so again you know i'll have to get that
specific date when official requests
were made i could tell you that um
specifically around the opp there was
resource uh supports that were given to
us in the very early days and
shortly after that resource uh supports
that were provided by the rcmp they have
been partners with us through the very
early days of this illegal occupation
but i will have to get and review our
documentation to see when the first
official requests were made to the
federal and provincial government
and
what were the enforcement tactics once
the situation did alter from a protest
to to an occupation
so again we that that will be
encompassed in the review that we're
occurring that will occur immediately
after this we we will fully cooperate
and support that review that was called
for by city council so that we can look
at steps and stages as to when different
mechanisms and levers were pulled to
both see how we could have been better
and see how we would change our
practices and tactics moving ahead to
never have this occurred
and
has any ultimatum ever been given to the
occupiers
have we
issued any notices to them um about the
illegal activity that they've been
engaged in
and if we did what were their
consequences
um so i would start with the notice
there isn't a time that i've come before
this board that i've become before
council or before media that we haven't
stated that this is an eagle illegal
occupation of our streets and these
people need to leave
um
the the support of that and the
enforcement of that is what is centered
around that plan that's being developed
and implemented by our integrated team
so there there has been no doubt that
these people are involved in an illegal
occupation of our streets through the
support of this board to the support of
council we are now seeing the relief
that we need through resource supports
planning support in order to be able to
bring it finally to an end
well i will just leave us with this
final thought uh that we've heard very
clearly from the residents of ottawa and
that uh is mirrored by um council and
i'm sure uh this body this board we need
a more proactive response
resources
and most importantly
enforcement effort to really end this
illegal occupation
that's what we need and we need a very
clear timeline we need a plan
and we need to present that relatively
quickly as quickly as possible uh to uh
the residents of ottawa so that we can
get to a resolution of this situation uh
that rightfully has uh really um
really is undermining um
trust in our public institutions
that's undermining uh trust
in
everything that is occurring in the city
and is erasing the idea of normalcy in
the city we need to bring this city back
to normal and we'll continue to advocate
for that and ask those questions
because this is not acceptable and
people out there and i agree with them
do not consider this
adequate and effective policing they
want to see that restored and they want
to see
results and so we'll continue to ask
those questions thank you chair
thank you very much
member king
member johnson
thank you chair
and i'll just add to counselor king's
comments i too
want to see our city back
our residents with their lives back as
soon as possible i would like to thank
past chief slowly for his work and
leadership during a very challenging
time
may i also
thank you acting chief val
the other members of the command team
and all of the ops members for for all
that you have done and will be doing to
end this occupation
and i was glad to hear that you as
acting chief
have shared that there is a plan
and that we will receive that at an
in-camera meeting
can i expect that meeting in the next 24
to 48 hours
so um first of all thanks for your
comments um
member johnson we we will be briefing
the board on the plan um at at the most
appropriate time prior to the
commencement of it i can't indicate when
that would be because that would be part
of the operations that we would be
engaging in
okay thank you
in terms of the incident command center
that's been set up have all three levels
of government been updated on the
incident command center
and has the decision-making process at
the leadership level been reviewed and
agreed upon by the opp the rcmp and the
ops
so um deputy chief ferguson has been
actively engaged in developing and
building that incident command center so
i'll turn that question over term
thank you member johnson for the
question
um i can tell you that as we are doing
now and have throughout this process um
we
they are updating their
boards and their
supervisors so the both commissioners
have been on daily calls with updates
with their members um and i think it's
suffice to say that all levels of
government are aware uh that the plan
that there is a plan and that they have
been contributing to it
okay and then my other question was has
the decision-making process at the
leadership level been agreed and
upon by the three different groups the
opp the rcmp and ops
yes they have sorry i admitted to
answering that
in in the command structure there are
levels across the board at which
decisions are made operational decisions
are made and it is the people who have
the best line of sight so not
necessarily the commissioner the chief
or the
commissioner of the rcmp who would be
making those decisions but they would be
advised of them
and they provide strategic direction to
them so that is happening
okay thank you
and then acting chief bell what
resources are still needed
in your estimation uh to end the ottawa
siege are you able to identify
what you still need
so again based on the need to
not disclose all of our operational
tactics in in a public forum what i can
tell you is
um the resources that we are requiring
to implement and execute on this plan
are being
coordinated and arranged through our
incident command center there will be
more in different resources that we'll
need that i won't go into specific
details on what they are in in a public
forum but they are being uh identified
and arranged to be accessed
okay thank you
so i would like to see the
communications improved on the actions
being taken and so i repeat on the
actions being taken to resolve this
occupation
acting chief bell i request you to
update the board
the board on a twice daily basis
until
this crisis is resolved
can you confirm that please that you'll
do that
maybe i'm going to step in here i
we're in the middle of a crisis i i i
really don't feel comfortable as a chair
of this board asking deputy chief bell
uh our
accurate story
interim chief bell
to
um update the board twice a day we have
a process in place that this board has
agreed to and we will commit to doing
that
um may i just clarify uh chair
uh the process that we've agreed to um
to make sure i'm clear on that thank you
we have agreed to any questions that the
board members have will be
bundled through the board office and
forwarded to the interim chief we will
have at least a once a week
meeting and if there are changes that we
need to consider in a
more fluid manner than i will call a
special meaning
yeah
um
i you know i
i do think given
that what i'm hearing from ottawa
residents that i've been speaking to
from the healthcare providers i've been
speaking
uh to that they're looking for more
action from the board
so
um given we're hearing that and how
critical it is
i ask again
that the board be updated by acting
chief bell these do not have to be long
updates if it's the following two
actions i've been taking that's fine
um
but i do request that the board receive
these updates and i think that we're
hearing
from ottawa and i'm seeing on twitter
that they want more from the board and i
want to do more and i want to show more
oversight
so
i uh
i again my request to acting and i s to
acting
chief bell
um so um
member johnson
i have to support or i will support um
what chair deans has indicated here um i
absolutely agree there isn't a person in
on this board in this building that
isn't looking to quickly effectively
safely resolve this occupation and get
these people out of our streets that is
all we are working towards
we have through our integrated command
center increased our communications
looked at how we have better more
refined messages on the actions that are
being taken but what i can tell you is
when when we attend and i think it's
important under the framework that's
been set up through the board when we
attend meetings like this it takes us
away from operationally responding to
the issue that's in front of us and at
the end of the day the most important
thing we're going to do is operationally
respond to this and get these people out
of our streets so although i absolutely
support having the most seamless
communication we can with the board to
provide them updates i can tell you the
twice daily briefings would be extremely
taxing and would be
very difficult to manage and would
absolutely take us away from an
operational response
can you see a level more than once a
week that could uh you know satisfy that
the board is doing the oversight that
ottawa wants us to do can you see
something uh
something different or something more
than that
so i'm i'm absolutely willing to work
with the board to to look at an enhanced
uh communications process if that's what
the board desires to chair deans um we
can look at how we can support that but
what i would ask is that we don't have
more in-person meetings where we take
the entire command structure away from
responding to the incident
right okay okay
that's helpful actually um yeah so uh
all right
and um
that that's all of my questions so thank
you very much
thank you member johnson um and
just before i start my comments i i just
want to say that
um
you know
um as much as we want to provide that
oversight role and we are expected to
i don't want to create the false
impression with the public that this
board has more authority in this than we
have that has been a problem already
with the public who happen to believe
that the board can direct these
operations and should be directing these
operations and i can tell you i have an
inbox full of people giving me advice
that under the act under the police
services act we cannot do so i
i just i want to caution the board not
to create the impression
at all with the public that ours is more
than an oversight role it's an oversight
role we have to make sure that we have
the the resources that they need we have
to make sure they have a plan we have to
ask those questions but we cannot direct
the chief and i don't want to leave the
impression with the public we can
because that is not the case and
i i like all of you and like every
single person i'm sure in the city wants
to see an expeditious and peaceful
safe and to this occupation where no one
is harmed we all want the same thing i
wanted as much as anybody else believe
me
we have to put a structure in place that
we believe
will get this job done as expeditiously
as possible and i guess chief bell i you
know i we're all getting into our
breaking point maybe i'm
too but um one of my frustrations has
been when we expect action we don't see
it it's a problem we expected coventry
road we sort of got half the job done
and then there seemed to be a backing
away it took way too long in
confederation park this weekend when we
said that we were going to treat the
protesters you know
more strongly than we have in the past
we had a chaotic carnival on parliament
hill i tell you i wanted to go up there
and pop that down to hot tub myself and
unplug the bouncy castle and i couldn't
understand why we weren't doing just
those things that were poking the
fingers in the eye of our house of
parliament of our democracy and of our
city and so you know if there's some
frustration spilling over it's okay now
we're getting the resources we this
board is working very hard behind the
scenes and i want to assure the public
that that is true to put a new structure
in place that will bring about a
peaceful end to this threat to this
illegal occupation as soon as possible
but i i think what the public needs to
hear today what i as the chair of this
board need to hear today is that there
is going to be stepped-up enforcement
and that the disruptive ridiculous
annoying
behavior that has persisted is going to
be
addressed in a meaningful and
expeditious fashion that's what we want
to hear
so chair deans i i i share your
frustration
i absolutely could not share your
frustration and it is the frustration
and and heartbreak of the residents that
live in this city we understand that we
work every single day to try and manage
and remove these people in a peaceful
way like you like you indicated um the
structures that we have brought in the
dedication of our members and the
members who are coming to our city to
actually remove these illegal occupiers
will be what ultimately ends this
um you you've heard trish talk today
you've heard myself talk today we have
worked with partners from the rcmp and
the opp who are experts in this who have
dealt with similar not to the scale uh
but similar type occupations in their
territory to bring their best
information their best reasoning and
their depth of experience into our house
into our city to come up with a plan
that will ultimately remove these people
from our streets i believe we have are
working on and have almost finalized
that plan with that plan comes
resourcing requests that you yourself
have asked for and we're seeing
fulfilled as we move ahead
everybody wants the same thing these
people need to leave they are not
welcome in our streets anymore we are
getting the resources we have the plan
and increasing our abilities to have
them remove go or removed from our
streets that is absolutely our intention
we hope we continue to work with the
demonstrators who have come here to have
them leave our streets we will continue
to do that until every last one of them
is gone
okay and i do agree with you that having
the rcap and the opp
having that level of knowledge uh upper
tier police services that have probably
dealt with more
uh um pro occupations of this scale than
the ottawa police services have in the
past is critical it's crucial it's
important i think it can make a
difference but i need to see the
difference
in term chief bell i need to see the
difference that it makes and what we
were our patients is wearing thin we
need
everybody
working
as best they can to get this thing
brought to a peaceful conclusion at the
earliest possible time and i can't
emphasize that enough remember nerman
sorry can i just one comment on that
charities um you absolutely could not
agree more we want as expeditiously as
we can to get this occupation finalized
one thing i will say though is nobody
across canada has ever dealt with an
occupation on this scope scale
size with this type of equipment or
vehicles in an area this is
unprecedented we said this from the
beginning this has not been
managed by any police service across
canada in the history of our country we
are continuing to work with them on
their best experience to manage what is
a new and unprecedented situation
just one more question how much more
complicated did this operation get with
the addition of 13 more trucks on
wellington street last night
so as we indicated we continue to work
to have a peaceful uh negotiated end to
this that was one of one of the steps
that was was done between um the city
and the the demonstrators um i won't
comment on the operational components of
it because i i don't think that would it
help us in our in executing our plan to
ultimately end this
thank you um member nerman
thank you chair uh
intelligent bill uh
sorry
uh
international bill uh i am building on a
member king
and especially
you would recall
that i had a discussion of section 63 of
the criminal code
during our first special meeting
and after hearing
that the ottawa police has not charged
anybody i have a follow-up question for
you please
illegal occupiers are committing crimes
crimes that are turning residents life
and local businesses upside down
without being arrested or even removed
the illegal occupiers have taken
complete control of the down core core
and i believe there is no doubt across
the board across the country on this
so so
steve bell my question is with those
facts in mind do you still believe that
the public is receiving adequate and
effective police services
so member norman i stand by my question
from before we are doing everything
within our power using all of our
resources and looking to implement and
execute on an integrated plan with the
rcmp and the opp to ultimately bring
this occupation to an end
i would say this was not uh i was
expecting a response but that's fine you
have the floor
uh my follow-up question is
are you making or planning to make some
intelligence and operational corrections
from the past on the moving forward
basis
so what i can what i can let you know is
every day through this uh unprecedented
occupation of our streets we've gathered
information gathered intelligence
learned from actions we've taken and
looked to refine them to have better
response on a go forward basis those
have all been built in to the plan that
we we are continuing to work on refined
develop and finalize with the opp and
the rcmp
okay thank you and uh before i leave i
would like to play some record the thank
you to all the ops
opp and rcp are rcmp frontline officers
including paramedics and the fire and
the civilian employees who have been in
service
including our former chief
peter slowly and yourself for stepping
up and taking some hard questions from
us thank you
thank you member nurman remember me
thank you chair um i'll i'll be pretty
quick um
interim chief
the i think um i think diane's emotions
sort of set uh a lot of our emotions uh
rolling as well we didn't want to be
overly uh emotional we wanted to be very
practical and get to the point of a lot
of the plans but i i have to say as a
resident of the city uh i i believe i
firmly believe that the majority of the
rank and file of our service are are
trying to do the best job they possibly
can but i am baffled and confused and
really frustrated when um i see videos
and i hear anecdotes of uh officers who
are um
uh
yucking it up with some of the
protesters and saying that they support
the cause and often sometimes are are
assisting them in some of the illegal
activities like moving cans around
can you just explain to the residents of
ottawa why this is happening and do
those officers really realize the damage
that they are doing to the to the
reputation of the ottawa police service
in this city
um
i realize that we're all we have all
different views we come from you know we
approach things differently but when it
comes to the police service we expect
them to uphold the rule of law and to
protect and represent the citizens not
the illegal occupiers
do they understand exactly what has
happened here and the long-term damage
that's going to be done to the service
because of this
so i want to focus on the the last part
of that answer first the vast vast
majority of the members of this police
service are out there every single day
trying to to restore law and order to
the community
and i agree
i know i know you did but i think it's
very important that it cannot be
understated they are out there working
with partners from across the country
and across the province other
municipalities to try and restore law
and order in this city they are as
frustrated and they
are as passionate about ending this as
every member of this board is as every
member of this community is i don't
think we can ever
lump everyone together and not say that
they're the vast vast majority of our
membership is working day and night to
try and end this in the best most lawful
most expeditious way that they can for
those that are not there is no place in
this police service i have said that
before and i will say that again
supporting illegal demonstrators illegal
occupiers in our streets is not part of
our core values you have my uh
commitment and my word as interim chief
that we will investigate every single
one of those and and to the fullest
extent ensure that those people are not
part of this police service
i i thank you on behalf of the citizens
of the city for that
because um it has undermined uh the
confidence that a lot of people have in
the police service and that as a member
of this board distresses me because
um we know that the majority of the
police service care deeply
um but i just want to address a rumor
that was going around and that was that
we were told uh just that the service
members were told just to keep the peace
and not to step in and not to take any
risks at all
um
i i think i asked the chief that a
couple weeks ago and uh he said that
wasn't true but is it is it in fact that
is in fact the case that's what's
happened right
that is not that is not what's happened
remember me and the the officers are
given the authorities that they have to
intervene within the demonstrators and
given the guidance and discretion to
intervene in a lawful and safe manner we
have to be considerate of officer safety
with with exactly the atmosphere the
chair deans explained there are pockets
within this and and our officers have
been involved in enforcement activities
where they've been swarmed so as
as we've asked for more resources and as
we've been provided more numbers we now
have the ability to increase our
enforcement activities to ultimately end
it there has been no complacency there
has been no direction given that members
should not enforce the laws there has
also been instructions given that they
have to do it within the bounds of
officer safety okay now that i've gone
this far i'll just ask the other one to
address the last rumor and that is that
um
several plans have been presented to the
executive of the ottawa police service
and they were uh rejected and
we're told that because we did not have
a plan that's why we weren't uh offered
the resources that we required earlier
so what i can let you know know that we
should be dealing in rumors in this
i just just a yes or no chair because it
is out there and there is some concern
about what i can let you know is we have
absolute support of our partners to
develop and staff a plan to ultimately
bring an end to the occupation we
continue to work on that we continue to
access staffing and resourcing to
execute that plan
thank you thank you
thank you acting chief thank you
thank you i know we want to wrap up soon
i have a couple more questions and i see
member king does and then i think we're
going to hold it there um
interim chief bell you said in response
to a question earlier that once a
vehicle
has left it's not allowed to return i
have received several messages from
members of the community saying that is
not factually correct so
i'm wondering if you can at least assure
us that going forward no vehicle that
leaves will be allowed to return
we are working every
everyday chair means to shrink the
footprint
i'm not sure of the information you're
receiving or the specific accounts but i
can tell you that we are actively um
have resources that are deployed it
takes several resources to keep the
footprint where it is and there is no in
and out privileges that we're allowing
in the in the demonstration
okay and my last question is um
interim chief bell would you agree with
me that there has been a colossal
failure of intelligence and that we need
to take immediate steps to make sure
that intelligence gathering is better
not just for this but going forward to
the future
uh so no i wouldn't agree that it's been
a colossal failure of intelligence um i
do we we have received intelligence on
going through this we have had our
intelligence networks
continuing to gather information um uh
what i wear will agree with you is in
this specific area which is an area that
has been unknown to us previously to
this we actually have to look at
alternative and better ways to collect
better more timely intelligence
information to be able to respond to
what's occurring we have developed some
of that capacity in the last a number of
weeks as this has unfolded in our city
but uh we did have an intelligence
network that was established we did
receive some intelligence on what was
what was occurring or what could occur
and those steps have been taken and
improved and enhanced on as we've
progressed through this
okay thank you remember king last
question to you and i'm just going to be
brief it's not really a question um i
just wanted to underline and understate
what you
noted share
that the police services board obviously
does not direct uh police tactics or
operations we live in a democracy but we
have specific institutions and we expect
the police to police
we have institutions and we know that
the police service under the police
services act is empowered with resources
the powers and the duty to enforce the
law
so what we've heard very clearly from
residents is that we want
they want and we collectively want that
task undertaken so that we can end uh
this illegal occupation forthwith and
the last uh item i'll leave you with is
i did submit questions uh over the
weekend of operational nature i'll be uh
submitting more uh questions of our
operational nature um after this meeting
and it will be my expectation to have um
those questions answered in a timely
fashion
thank you so much chair
thank you and remember nerman we only
have a few more minutes for this meeting
is
just a very brief very brief comment
and again i am coming to
interim chief bell uh on his adequate
and effective police services
what my experience is
i am 60 years
that whenever the community members of
the community they come on the road
and they try to enforce the law with no
respect or no
faith in the police that is the end of
it
so instead in spite of that this weekend
we saw how on elgin riverside
they were they were stopping the
protesters to go to the downtown core
and in spite of that if the words is
coming that police was providing or is
providing adequate and
effective services
i won't take that but thank you that was
my comment
okay um so received on the update
received
and then item number two the appointment
of special constables carlton university
that the ottawa police services board
approved the appointment of carlton
university employees jamie baldwin
and mark prince cox's special
consequence pursuant to section 53 of
the police services act in accordance
with the terms and conditions set forth
in the attached approval of appointment
form is the item carried
all right
thank you this concludes our public
agenda i would now call for um um a
motion to adjourn
remember meehan
favor
carried thank you very much everyone
be safe out there have a good day thank
you
you